self-consciousness which I'm whole knows
itself to be reality has its object in
its own self but as an object which
initially is merely for
self-consciousness and does not as yet
possess objective being which confronts
it as a reality other than its own and
self-consciousness by behaving as a
being for self aims to see itself as
another independent being this primary
end is to become aware of itself as an
individual in the other
self-consciousness or to make this other
into itself it is certain that this
other is in principle already itself in
so far as it has lifted itself out of
the ethical substance and the tranquil
being of thought to its being for self
it has left behind the law of custom and
existence the knowledge acquired through
observation in theory as a gray shadow
which is in the act of passing out of
sight for the latter is rather a
knowledge of something whose being for
self in actuality or other than those of
this self-consciousness instead of the
heavenly seeming spirit of the
universality of knowledge in action
which the feeling and enjoyment of
individuality are still there is entered
into it the spirit of the earth for
which true actuality is merely that
being which is the actuality of the
individual consciousness it despises
intellect and science the supreme gifts
of man it has given itself to the devil
and must perish
here entering paragraph 360 it's worth
taking a little bit of a pause and
looking at the structure of the work
that we're now right in the middle of so
this is the first paragraph in a very
short section a subsection of a
subsection called pleasure and necessity
list and note vindicate what's going on
here is a dialectical development and
we're gonna see two other ones occurring
that are a bit longer the one having to
do the law of the heart and then the
other one having to do with virtue and
in each of these we begin with something
that is a common human experience is
something that we can you might say
commit ourselves to and live our way
through and learn about in the process
and that people have been doing
throughout history this becomes
particularly acute in the modern period
but it's not as if we don't have a lot
of you might say evidences or narratives
of this in the ancient period and it's
across cultures as well
now what Hegel is discussing here if we
look at the paragraphs that we've just
proceeded through is how the individual
self-consciousness the reasoning human
being is trying to find and to pursue
their glueck their happiness what is
happiness how should we understand it
how should we conceive of it what do we
need to do in order to enjoy happiness
and what do we learn in the process what
we're going to see in each of these
sections is that happiness is always
something that we're you know we've got
a clear sight at and we're pursuing and
then somehow we would grasp turns out
not to be yet we also learn in the
same process that what we thought we
were pursuing leads us into a different
path and now we come face-to-face with
something else than what we were
striving for originally which then
Prime's us for moving into another
dialectical progression these are what
Hegel calls the shapes of consciousness
Gestalt n' just alton does the with
signs and what we're seeing here is
something that can play itself out in an
entire culture you know in groups in
individuals and Hegel is focusing here
primarily on the individual now why is
he beginning with pleasure well there's
a few things to say about this before we
actually get into paragraph 361 is if
you're looking for an exposition of
hedonism and its flaws and faults that
is particularly vivid or concrete this
is not the place to look as a matter of
fact I don't think that you can find a
more abstract and I don't say boring
abstract the way some some abstract
treatments are but a more abstract
treatment of something that we think
that we know all about that is pleasure
right and hedonism the the pursuit of
pleasure as the good for the human being
what we see in here in Hegel is just the
barest sketch of what pleasure might in
fact be there's no lingering over any
concrete examples there is a reference
to goethe's faust
but it's really just in terms of this
you know spirit of the earth and so we
have to do a lot of filling in the gaps
ourselves and so that's part of why I
put this over here and we'll come back
to this in in a moment because I think
it's it's important for us to try to
keep in mind some some concrete examples
of what he might be talking about and to
specify what Hegel is is not actually
talking about when he's talking about
pleasure
you know I'll just reveal this when he's
talking about pleasure he's not talking
about the pleasure that a person might
get say in taking drugs or drinking
alone or something like that he seems to
have something more in mind that it
involves another self-consciousness so
we'll come back to that in a moment
so all that said he says self
consciousness knows itself to be reality
has its object in its own self but as an
object which initially is merely for
self consciousness and does not as yet
possess objective being which confronts
it as a reality other than its own so
self consciousness grasps itself in its
relation to its objects you know in in
part the whole world but here we're
talking about as commentators have
recognized no longer the world as the
world of just material objects but a
social world the world of imbued and
shared meanings and self-consciousness
the individual self consciousness has
broken with that in certain respects
broken from the ethical substance so he
goes on and he says self consciousness
by behaving as a being for self aims to
see itself as another independent being
so in being conscious of itself and
setting aims or goals or trying to
satisfy its own desires or having a
self-image or thinking about itself in
certain ways self consciousness is
trying to discover what in fact it
really is and it doesn't want to have
just a vague notion of this it wants to
grasp it in its essence and so what
we're talking about here in terms of
pleasure is grasping itself in terms of
its
own activity of pursuing and enjoying
pleasure so you might say you know
there's a lot of tell me who you are
things out there right Bri that's never
an has you know tell me what you eat and
I'll know what you are roughly
paraphrased right other people say it
tell me what you read and I'll tell you
who you are right Hegel is considering
the the you might say possibility or the
tradition even of saying you know a
person through their pleasures a person
knows him or herself through enjoyment
there's really something to that by the
way and I don't want to to have that
left out of the picture and I don't
think Hegel does either but it's going
to be somewhat limited and one-sided as
we'll see so he goes on he says this
primary end is to become aware of itself
as an individual in the other
self-consciousness the individual wants
to make sense wants to understand wants
to grasp itself in the other
self-consciousness he says or to make
this other into itself it is certain
that this other is in principle already
itself now you says insofar as its
lifted itself and I you know don't have
self the ethical substance down here I
have it up here because it has lifted
itself in a way it's revolted you might
say it's realized that what the ethical
substance set up for itself its role its
economic processes all those sorts of
things don't exhaust its own meaning the
self consciousness has lifted itself out
of this realm of the ethical substance
and Hegel names several of the aspects
of that in doing so he says it's it's
it's left the tranquil being of thought
- it's being herself
it has left behind the law of custom in
existence the knowledge acquired through
observation and
theory which is a great shadow which is
in the act of passing out of sight he
says that is the knowledge of something
whose being for self in actuality are
other than those of this
self-consciousness now that is a very
interesting thing for Hegel to say isn't
it because you know we know Hegel is an
idealist right so he's supposed to be
all about theory and all about knowledge
we know that he thinks that the the
society you know the culture is where
spirit really resides so the law of
customer if you like mores zipa and
existence design all of those things are
you know what we should be saying oh
yeah that's that's very very important
self-consciousness in going against
those things in in minimizing them you
could say is in fact limiting itself it
is it is tearing itself out of its
matrix of meaning where it can do things
well yes that's true in a sense and it
also leaves something out we like to
have fun we like to enjoy ourselves it's
not all about being minds that then just
happen to have bodies and maybe like the
card says you know the the pilot and the
ship steers the body around to do things
no and Hegel is somebody if you want to
call him an idealist he is a materialist
idealist meaning that our body is the
locus for our agency for our experience
of the totality of existence and desire
and pleasure are an integral part of
that it could be you know as you know
innocent to pleasure as sitting in the
Sun and basking in its rays it could
as de blotched a pleasure is anything
you could possibly find through you know
some some hunting and seeking on on the
internet right but that's going to be an
integral part of our existence and
that's where we end up moving away it's
individuals who enjoy pleasure right so
he goes on and he says instead of the
heavenly seeming spirits of the
universality of knowledge and action in
which the feeling and enjoyment of
individuality are still that would be
you know this ethical swamp sense there
is entered into it the something else
the spirit of the earth for which true
actuality is merely that being which is
the actuality of the individual
consciousness what is real what is true
even which is more than what is real for
Hegel there's more to be said about that
but at this point what is real is the
being of the individual consciousness
its actuality you know the prosaic
example of this you know in graduate
school we used to have these great
seminars and we'd sit in the classroom
and we'd be like you know reading Adel's
phenomenology of spirit I was actually
reading it in German at the time there's
an old long story about that and the old
German script and then going you know
line by line through through the the
text with the rest of the class and then
we would have a break and we would all
go though those of us who smoked we'd
all go downstairs and go outside and get
our cigarettes out and start smoking
away and enjoying ourselves and then
we'd start talking some more about what
was going on in the class and that was
an important part of the actual class it
was not part of the syllabus it was not
part of anything else but it was you
know a time to reflect a time to come
a time to share and it was a time to do
so precisely in order to satisfy our
bodies and our addicted minds desire for
a certain kind of pleasure and we could
go on and on and on with examples like
this now he's got this beautiful quote
from Goethe that that you know the
English doesn't really do justice to it
despises intellect in science the
supreme gifts of man
it has given itself to the devil and
must perish from goethe's faust what
he's talking about there is he's using
that as a sort of you know way of
highlighting the individuality of
pleasure seeking and pleasure taking now
I said we're going to mention kinds of
pleasure and this is important as we're
moving into this section to talk about
this so there's a lot of different ways
in which we could enjoy pleasure right
there's a sort of pleasure about being
in an environment or you know is person
in relation to world going out into a
forest you know if you really do see the
trees and don't see the forest you're
not enjoying the forest right at a
certain point you need to be encompassed
by what you're enjoying same thing going
out and fishing on the lake as something
I very much enjoy you know there's
something about the dappling of the
water and the sounds and you know you do
catch a fish here and there if you're
lucky but but a lot of it is the you
know looking into this expanse of waves
moving back and forth reflecting the sky
reflecting other things then there's a
person's enjoy experiences or things you
know drinking is a great example of that
it's fun to drink right I particularly
like to drink IPAs because I enjoy the
particular bitterness and the hop taste
and you know the the buzz that comes
along with it and you know
different other things the mouthfeel of
the the beer you know we could talk
about all sorts of other things some
people like drinking whiskey some people
like drinking absinthe I've never tried
that but I've heard it's quite
interesting
some people like doing other things you
know taking other things that affect the
body in different ways and it might not
be about the sense of taste or smell at
that point it might merely be the the
effect of the drug on the body but
that's not experiencing another person
right
that's not a relation of
self-consciousness to the other
self-consciousness unless you're you
know hallucinating and you think that
you're you're the drug that you're
taking is somehow sentient or it's
something like that that's not what
Hegel has in mind actually when he's
talking about hedonism here and pleasure
person and another person there's a good
argument to be made in interpreting this
paragraph and the next two paragraphs to
come that maybe Hegel is talking about
something like romantic involvement or
even you know physical love or sexuality
I I don't know to me it seems a little
bit iffy but in part that's a good thing
because it means that we could also be
talking about the conversation that
we're having with somebody or enjoying
you know something but sometimes we are
you know trying to enjoy the other
person and perhaps the other person is
trying to enjoy us as well hopefully
that's the case and so we've got a
different kind of pleasure there in
person to other person and we have
person with other person's right we like
watching the game together we enjoy
going fishing together we sit around and
drink some really good coffee together
or something along those lines and
remarket and our pleasure is enhanced by
the fact that we are sharing it with
another human being
another self-consciousness and then I
think we also need
in mind that for many people pleasure is
something that they do conspicuously and
they do it because they think that they
ought to enjoy it because other people
have told them that they human beings do
enjoy it and they are human being so
they better get with the program and try
that out and enjoy it and sometimes our
pleasure is is done so that we can have
other people seeing us enjoying that
pleasure
now when Hegel is talking about I think
is primarily these two pleasure in the
other person pleasure with the other
person so keep that in mind as we move
into these sections
it plunges therefore into life and
indulges to the full the pure
individuality in which it appears it
does not so much make its own happiness
as straightway take it and enjoy it the
shadowy existence of science laws and
principles which alone stand between it
and its own reality vanishes like a
lifeless mist which cannot compare with
the certainty of its own reality it
takes hold of life much as a ripe fruit
is plucked which readily offers itself
to the hand that takes it
paragraph 361 is very exciting and for
those of us who enjoyed pleasure
particularly in our youth once we got
over particular hang-ups and realize
just how much there was out there and in
the world to to appreciate and to enjoy
it may come as an interesting
reminiscence something that we can can
relate to what we're gonna find of
course later is that it's empty but
right now we want to look at sort of the
first blush of the the pursuit of
pleasure as Hegel's depicting it so he
talks about well let's look at the text
itself he says it plunges therefore into
life and indulges to the full the pure
individuality in which it appears so
what is it there it is
self-consciousness the self-conscious
individual the person and it plunges
itself into life remember that life for
Hegel has this this sense of like a
plenitude of different actualities and
possibilities there may be something
like a you know booming buzzing
confusion like like like James you know
talks about later on involved in this
but life is this this expanse that
cannot be contained so it jumps right
into the life and it does so and it
takes on the form of pure individuality
it because it's not absolutely necessary
that a self-consciousness be pure
individuality it's interesting if you
think of it there's there's quite a few
social theories that begin with the
individual right because that's what
they want to find in the end is that
individual but you know Hegel tends to
be a little skeptical of those sorts of
views the individual never turns out to
be a pure individual like you know this
island by itself but in pleasure and
pleasure seeking and pleasure taking and
pleasure enjoying that's probably where
we
come closest to it and it makes you
suspect that under these you know
high-minded theories of individualism
there might not just be a kind of
hedonism lurking below the surface so
Hegel says it plunges into life right an
area says it does not so much make its
own happiness
it's not a active laborious process
instead it's finding in life what can
make it happy it takes it he says it
takes it and enjoys it
doesn't build it it doesn't in a certain
sense earn it right it just goes out and
get that and other people who have this
is a kind of advice hey man you're young
go enjoy yourself go go do this go do
that right and it gets even more stark
here because he says the shadowy
existence of science laws and principles
right this and shaft remember this this
is all about visiting chef Gazette Singh
this could be laws in the sense of like
you know the laws that you have to obey
cuz that's what your society tells you
it can also be like psychological laws
logical laws that we saw in the earlier
observing reason section and principles
groans etson all right a very abstract
way of talking here so fundamental
fundamental you know adages about how
you ought to behave oh that becomes
shadowy when presented with the
possibility of getting your happiness
through pursuing certain kinds of
pleasures and so you know this is an
experience that some of us have had I
think he says these these you know are
shadowy they loan stand between it that
is self-consciousness and pure
individuality they vanish like a
lifeless mist which cannot compare with
the certainty of its own reality I you
know I go to the party and I drink and I
feel you know
and I'm enjoying the environment and I
see somebody who's attractive over there
and I start up a conversation with them
and I'm having a great time and there is
my friends over there and there's
something cool happening over there this
stuff who cares about that it you know
it naturally loses its efficacy its
weight it becomes insubstantial so he
says self-consciousness takes hold of
life much as a ripe fruit is plucked
which readily offers itself to the hand
that takes it so this sounds pretty good
as far as a depiction of the pursuit of
pleasure doesn't it this is something I
think we can recognize this is what
hedonism looks like in practice
it's action is only in one respect an
action of desire it does not aim at the
destruction of objective being its
entirety but only at the form of its
other Nisour its independence which is a
show devoid of essence for it holds this
objectivity to be in principle the same
essence of itself or itself would the
element in which desired its object
subsist as mutually indifferent and
independent its is animate existence the
enjoyment of desire puts an end to this
existence so far as it belongs to the
object of desire but here this element
which gives to both a separate actuality
is rather the category a being which is
essentially in the form of thought it is
therefore the consciousness of
independence let it be natural
consciousness or consciousness developed
into a system of laws which preserves
the individuals each for it himself this
separation is not itself a fact for self
consciousness which knows the other as
its own self would it attains therefore
to the enjoyment of pleasure to the
consciousness of its actualization and a
consciousness which appears as
independent or to the vision of the
unity of the two independent self
consciousnesses it attains its end but
only to learn there what the truth of
that end is it comprehends itself as
this particular individual who exists
for himself but the realization of this
end is itself the setting aside of the
latter for it is not as this particular
individual that it becomes an object to
itself but rather as the unity of itself
and the other self consciousness hence
as an individual that is only a moment
or a universal
by the end of paragraph 362 we're going
to see Hegel beginning to show us how
the seeking of pleasure as the happiness
for the independent self-consciousness
turns out to be not illusory as such but
it just doesn't provide what it's
supposed to and it ends up transmuting
into something that's not quite its
opposite but it certainly is something
very different than what the person was
aiming for or looking for so this is
actually the paragraph that I think
leads commentators to think that here
what he means by pleasure is you know at
least not exclusively but in its
paradigm sexual pleasure the pleasure of
enjoying intimacy or engagement or
however you want to frame it - maybe
just getting it on with another body but
a body that isn't just a lifeless limp
thing but is another human being where
there's a back-and-forth there there's a
connection there right and what he's
sketching out it can fit that I think it
could fit a lot of other things as well
so what does Hegel say says it's action
is only it is only in one respect an
action of desire what why is it in only
one respect well he says it doesn't aim
at the destruction of the object the way
that it did earlier in the
self-consciousness section when we
talked about the geardo or desire
instead what it wants to do is to have
that object sort of remaining in place
while it continues to enjoy it and
thereby knows itself in that object so
he says it doesn't aim at the
destruction of its objective being in
its entirety only at the form of its
other nests or its independence it holds
this objectivity to be in principle the
same essence as itself or its cell
hood it's engaging with the other with
the the object and it doesn't want the
object to be something foreign to it
something that has its own self
subsistence that can disappoint it that
won't respond in the way that it wants
and there's there's kind of a dynamic
here you know you gotta be you gotta be
very careful that you don't make the
object too much like yourself or else
you're really just enjoying yourself
right and then it doesn't become quite
so enjoyable but you don't want the
object to be so independent that it can
decide to say no I'm not going to give
you what you want so he goes on he says
the element in which desire and its
objects subsist as mutually indifferent
and independent is animus existence all
right so it's not just commodities it's
you might say it's commodities that have
been connected with other human desire
this is a very important point so he
goes on when he says the the enjoyment
of desire puts an end to this animate
existence insofar as it belongs to the
object of desire but here this element
which gives to both a separate actuality
is rather the category of being which is
essentially in the form of thought now
that's that's a weird thing to say that
this point isn't it we're talking a
pleasure and we're talking about
desiring and the object and now suddenly
Hegel says well it's really about the
category and that's that's a form of
thought and you might say what could be
more foreign to thought the abstract
thought then pleasure think back to salt
is to sense certainty and how since
certainty was supposed to be the most
concrete the most in your face the most
you just right it's right there just you
know waiting for you to get it then it
turned out upon analysis to be as Hegel
said the most abstract kind of knowledge
didn't it it was farthest from reality
from the object from a connection
between us in the world
pleasure has the same kind of dynamic
going on here so he goes on and he says
it's there for the consciousness of
Independence let it be natural
consciousness or consciousness developed
into a system of laws doesn't make any
difference
right he says the separation is not
itself a fact for self consciousness
which knows the other is its own self
hood
it attains therefore to the enjoyment of
pleasure to the consciousness of its
actualization in a consciousness which
appears as independent or to the vision
of the unity the two independent self
consciousness is this the sprocket met
the unity of the two independent self
consciousness is I think is why
commentators have thought of this in
terms of sexual desire and attraction
and activity and pleasure in that sense
but I don't think that that has to be
our only possibility for understanding
it the point is that pleasure occurs by
not just being all by yourself say
shooting up or you know getting yourself
off or drinking and watching you know -
even if you're just watching TV you're
not just drinking you're watching
stories that other people are telling
right so sort of a substitute for
another self consciousness you lose
yourself in that by the way
so Hegel is telling us that pleasure
does get its enjoyment a desire does get
its enjoyment in pleasure right but then
it goes beyond that
it starts others start stuff starts
trickling in you might say metaphysical
stuff starts trickling in and that's
where we're getting to here water what
are the things that are coming in two
main things consciousness of
independence which is a correlate you
don't get the object as independent that
you can then sub late or you know I'll
pay but yeah oh Haven in German that you
can transcend and and somehow connect
back to yourself
it really does have independence we saw
this back when we looked at the other
developments of self-consciousness in
the self-consciousness section didn't we
the here it goes further the individual
self-consciousness becomes aware of the
unity of itself with this other
self-consciousness to which it is
connected in its desiring its action its
pleasure taking and this means as Hegel
says that it attains its end only to
learn there what the truth of that end
is was really interesting framework it
comprehends itself is this particular
individual who exists for himself but
the realization of the if this end is
itself the setting aside of this ladder
the ladder is the real is the
comprehending itself as a particular
individual who exists for himself
in trying to exist for yourself and to
do so through the mode of pleasure
inevitably you find out that you're not
just for yourself you're stuck in a
world of other people sometimes you find
this out by screwing things up right by
taking your pleasure and then somebody
else says hey that hurts or hey you
screwed things up for me you know yeah I
guess there are other other beings
involved here is can be a painful
reality right but here's the upshot of
that through this this awareness of
unity he says so as it's not as this
particular individual that it becomes an
object to itself the the
self-consciousness but rather as the
unity of itself and the other
self-consciousness it knows itself in
relation to others but that means it's
an individual that is only a moment or
is a universal now what is this
universal that's what remains to be
discovered in the rest of this set of
paragraphs